[Music]
imagine what would happen if you left a
type of bird for example finches alone
on a lush planet without predators for
hundreds of millions of years what kinds
of incredible forms of life might evolve
if you consider that mammals grew from a
few rodent-like species into elephants
whales horses bats and primates in a
much shorter period after the extinction
of the dinosaurs you'll start to realize
just how incredible things might get
this concept is the idea behind one of
the most detailed speculative biology
projects ever created
serena the world of birds this epic
multi-million year journey was created
by dylan beta an incredible artist and
writer and i have links below where you
can follow and support his work there's
so much incredible detail to this
project and i won't be able to cover it
all in a single video but for now let's
get started at the very beginning of the
saga with the introduction of life to
the moon of serena
the story begins when some force perhaps
aliens or advanced humans places earth
life forms on the moon of serena
specifically they put canaries into a
terraformed ecosystem much like earth's
a few other species including grasses
algae flowering plants like sunflowers
tiny fish like guppies and swordtails
and insects like ants and crickets are
also left on the planet to create a
sustainable food source for the finches
which are the only significant land
animals on this entire moon and then the
creators of this mysterious experiment
depart and evolution takes over
the explosion in canary diversity is
almost instantaneous the artist
speculates that lacking predators and
with a near endless food supply the
population would skyrocket over the
first ten thousand years from here early
specialization emerges with insect
eaters plant eaters egg eaters and seed
eaters all becoming subtly different
over the generations in the sea guppies
and swordtails grow and diversify over
the next several million years this
period which is called the hypostasine
sees small fish become larger and more
streamlined with hydrodynamics shaping
them into familiar forms
several million years in and leafcutter
ants have quickly proliferated with
their numbers reaching tens of billions
soon larger flightless variants of
canaries emerge to feed on this growing
food source as the sun rises 10 million
years into this grand experiment a truly
diverse ecosystem of different species
is forming here the thick beaked axe
pills strut across the plains near the
large wamblers and long-legged art geese
already the moon of serena is a much
different place from when these birds
first arrive and from here things will
only get stranger
11 million years in an era called the
tempestine begins marked by a steady
cooling and an increase in arid
environments a region called the
northern dry lands comprises the largest
temperate desert region on this moon
where all sorts of new species are
emerging it's now early spring here and
a large and life-ard goosed offshoot is
strutting across the drylands keeping an
eye on fearsome descendants of the
formerly herbivorous ax bills called the
skykes which are now sharp build
omnivores nearby one of the first true
predators on serena the small falconary
hunts a songbird under the branches of
huge tree-like sunflowers descendants
but below them all in a series of
tunnels an even more interesting dynamic
is unfolding these tunnels are made by
an enormous lobster-like arthropod which
despite weighing as much as a small cat
is in fact a cricket and with it in its
home are strange little birds called
ground sarins they can't dig tunnels
themselves but make use of the friendly
cricket's burrow to keep themselves safe
and in return act as lookouts a very
strange set of roommates indeed as the
tempestantic era progresses serena
continues to cool in this changing
environment the artist imagines one
successful branch of art geese called
the vivas is on the path to a surprising
yet useful adaptation the birth of life
young without requiring an egg and in
the coming ice age this adaptation will
prove vital to the branch's success away
from the mainland however the isolated
crying islands are not yet feeling the
effects of the global cooling indeed on
these islands where food grows in
abundance and predators are scarce very
different selective pressures are
creating some of the largest and
strangest species of birds so far
reaching heights of over ten feet or
three meters the chub birds are huge
offshoots of finches that don't resemble
any other birds on serena at this time
in this paradise there's simply nothing
big enough on these islands to bother
them in time though the islands change
the chub birds pass on and in their
place and even stranger species of
megafauna emerge these are the snuffalos
shaggy heavyset creatures almost the
size of cattle and with similar grazing
behavior the snuffaloes are so heavy
however that they can't support their
weight on their two feet alone and must
also rely on their beak for balance
which has almost become a third foot
inefficient perhaps but there are few
predators on these islands that would
make the snuffalo require speed save
perhaps for one the butcher raptor is an
evolutionary newcomer and not large
enough to seem like a threat to
something snuffalo sized but the butcher
raptor has something the snuffalo does
not intelligence butcher raptors are
quite possibly the smartest creatures
serena has yet to produce efficient pack
hunters that can in a group take down
something as big as a snuffalo and in
the oceans life is also diversifying
into unexpected forms take for example
the sword sharks predators whose
swordtail ancestors average 6 inches in
length the sword shark in contrast
averages up to eight feet and preys on
vast shoals of smaller fish thrashing
them with their unique tails to stun
them an even more incredible
transformation has occurred in the case
of the giant gemnas a guest entry into
serena conceptualized by joseph cawley
the giant geminis grows over 30 feet or
9 meters in length and consumes over 400
pounds or 180 kilos of plant matter a
day and yet the ancestors of these
herbivorous behemoths are the tiny
guppies truly aquatic birds called
balloons also emerged during the
tempestine like the starry peli carrier
a species that incubates eggs under its
hind legs and carries its young safely
in its mouth right now these early
seafaring birds are far from the largest
things in the ocean about the size of a
human diver in the future however the
circumstances for the balloons would
change however it's not the balloons nor
even the giant geminis that one should
be keeping an eye on long term these
tiny unfortunate almost toad looking
creatures are called mud wickets they're
a species of fish that lives in tidal
areas and are beginning the process of
crawling onto land right now they're not
up to much but there are many millions
of years to go in our great epic
looking back on serena's progress 50
million years have now passed since the
introduction of the canaries and the
moon is now entering a period called the
cryoscene the climate already cooling in
the tempest scene has now cooled further
and over half the moon's surface is
locked in ice in this new frontier the
live-bearing vivas groups have come to
dominate all manner of niches both at
the equator and in the colder regions
from large tropical shimmer snoot vivas
who eat insects with their long tongues
to the leith herbivorous cerelopes and
thick beaked carnivorous banshees of the
plains to the tiny bumblets who burrow
underground to keep warm the vivas have
become one of the most diverse groups in
this new world another successful vivas
is the canaraboo large thick-coated
offshoots of cerelopes that live in
enormous migratory herds and can
withstand the harsh polar winters of
this region the kinerabou is the first
true live-bearing bird giving birth to
fully hatched infants here a mother
protects its newborn from a giant
falconry aerial predators that have
grown gigantic over the ages but are not
so large they're ready to tangle with an
angry mother protecting its young in the
tall forests of pine flowers plants
which have evolved conifer-like needles
the more familiar descendants of
egg-laying species hold on in this more
temperate region the giant flightless
anvil beak with a beak that helps it
crack open all manner of seeds lives
near its cousins the sword bills who are
lightweight hunters these holdovers are
distant descendants of theax bills and
in these forests their lineage will
endure despite the dropping temperatures
another familiar though increasingly
strange species
are the mole birds the descendants of
the burrowing finches who are now
capable diggers in their own right for
millions of years they've quietly
tunneled underground content to be
ignored by the above ground megafauna
also much changed since our last visit
are the aquatic balloons which are now
one of the most specialized lineages of
birds on serena growing to more than 60
feet or 18 meters in length and weighing
up to 15 000 pounds or six thousand
eight hundred kilograms this is a family
of gentle herbivorous leviathans which
the artist describes as the largest
birds that have ever existed and at the
water's edge the unassuming mud wickets
have continued to adapt spending more
and more time on land they still don't
look like much but soon circumstances
will change
but the time of the mud wickets is not
yet upon us jumping forwards to the late
cryo scene the final period we'll be
covering in this particular video we've
arrived at an age of giants on the
plains one large offshoot of the
cerelope are the flutterbox colorful
herbivores with a bright plumage similar
in many ways to the feathers of earth's
peacocks the flutterbox are in turn
stalked by the dinosaur-like trunk
snouts whose newly evolved pseudo teeth
make them effective predators with a
high degree of evolutionary potential
even more dinosaur-like or the sarah
striders the largest terrestrial bird
that is yet to evolve on serena
exceeding 12 meters or 40 feet in height
and weighing several tons the sarah
striders are the sauropods of their day
adapted to browse the highest branches
of trees but larger herbivores mean
larger carnivores the tyrant sarins the
grandest of all descendants of the
distant axe bill are apex predators that
can take down other large megafauna
equipped with serrated beaks able to
shatter bone these tyrants are the
heaviest land predators yet to evolve
this period is an early peak of
megafauna on serena which now supports
species so large and distinct they're
almost unrecognizable when one reflects
on the moon's first humble inhabitants
over the next several million years
serena would change once again as an
increase in volcanic eruptions on a
larger scale than ever before would turn
the environment on its head giving rise
to far more alien looking creatures than
what we've seen so far which we'll
explore in our next installment but for
now that's all the time we have if you
enjoyed learning about the moon of
serena consider supporting and following
dylan beta using the links below also
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
entry please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
see you in the next video